Proteins are everywhere in our bodies,
and they can do lots of amazing things.
Like tools, the shape of the protein is
very important. For example, scissors
have multiple blades that help it cut
things, while screwdrivers have a
shaped end that allow it to fit into a
screw. Without the proper shape, the
protein would not be able to perform
its job. Proteins don't start out,
though, in their final shape. To become
the proper shape, proteins need to go
through a process called protein
folding.
Proteins are made up of building blocks
called amino acids. These amino acids
are placed into chains, known as
polypeptides.
To become the final protein, the
polypeptide needs to fold into its
proper shape. But how do proteins know
what shape to fold into? Amino acids in
a polypeptide follow a wide variety of
rules to fold into the final protein.
For example, some amino acids love
water, while others dislike water,
which could affect where those amino
acids are placed in the protein. Other
amino acids enjoy being close to each
other and can form bonds so that they
stay next to each other in the final
protein. However, protein folding is
incredibly complex, and there are many
other rules to help ensure that
proteins fold properly.
Because proteins are everywhere in our
body and perform many jobs, it is
important that they fold into the
proper shape. If proteins don't have
the right shape, that can cause
problems, like clumping together. These
problem proteins can play a role in
diseases, like Alzheimer's and mad cow
disease. Luckily, our body has a number
of ways to deal with misfolded proteins.
They can get rid of the problem
proteins or use proteins, called
chaperones, to help fix and refold
proteins into the proper shape. We're
still learning so much about the exact
rules for how proteins fold and how the
shape of a protein can teach us about
the job it performs. Understanding both
of these can help us understand not
only how proteins work, but how to
treat diseases related to problems of
protein folding